with just one year in office president
pedro castillo is now facing six
criminal inquiries and the federal
investigations are getting closer and
closer to home
a sister-in-law suspected of awarding
government contracts to friends turned
herself in a nephew suspect of receiving
bribes is a fugitive and one of
castillo's top allies a former transport
minister in charge of the government's
largest budget is nowhere to be found
castillo says the media is trying to
portray his family as corrupt
his defense lawyer has requested the
judiciary stop the press from publishing
any information regarding the
president's case castillo says he's a
victim of racism
they are against this government because
i come from the countryside it's totally
racist i do not speak like them or sit
at their opulent tables because i walk
with the people
seventy percent of peruvians now think
he's guilty
frustrated that nearly all former
presidents are involved in corruption
peruvians marched in support of the
public prosecutor leading the probes
castillo's allies say the investigations
are politically motivated
i firmly reject the claims and
insinuations that the public
prosecutor's office is part of an
alleged political plan
an opinion paul says 24 of peruvians
think he's innocent and continue to
support the 52 year old former rural
teacher and farmer castillo says he's
cooperating with prosecutors in each
investigation but every time he goes to
testify before them he asserts his right
to remain silent and says not another
word
he has taken the absurd decision of not
making his judicial situation clear a
politician cannot simply remain silent
before a prosecutor a politician must be
accountable transparent and castillo is
the least transparent leader in our
history
castillo has survived two impeachment
attempts but now former allies are
testifying against him in the face of so
many investigations unprecedented for a
sitting president his days in office may
be numbered mariano sanchez al jazeera
lima peru